everything he says he's a liar he's not
who he says he is I've literally been
saving face I did not want to come to
the world and let you guys know what he
has been doing to me my entire
relationship with him he is a woman
beater and the NBA needs to know this
[Music]
I literally did not want to come to this
because I know he has so many
endorsements but Zion Williamson is a
woman beater oh why and the reason he
was paying me off is so I won't come to
the world and tell everybody
oh my God shut the you're telling
me this guy needs to beat women the guy
one of the best guys in the NBA so much
so that me who knows nothing about the
NBA knows who he is you're telling me
this guy needs to beat women like this
is just mad she didn't get her 62k